This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In San Francisco, the area south of Market Street is called Soma. The part of town north of the Panhandle is known as Nopa. Just north of our office is a part of town that Oakland is trying to brand as Kono, short for Koreatown Northgate. But no one actually calls it that. I live in a part of town at the intersection of North Oakland, Berkeley, and Emoryville. A neighborhood real estate brokers are calling No-B. That's producer Avery Trollflam.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在旧金山，市场街以南的区域被称为Soma。城中北部的部分被称为Nopa。就在我们办公室北边，有一片区域奥克兰正试图将其打造为Kono，即Koreatown Northgate（韩国城北门）的缩写。但实际上没人这么叫它。我住的地方位于北奥克兰、伯克利和埃默里维尔的交界处。房地产经纪人把这个社区称为No-B。那是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。
The home No-B thing makes me feel pretty icky. These abbreviated neighborhood names are such clichés. Like, there's that episode of South Park where part of town gets rebranded as South of downtown South Park, or Sodo Sopa. There's a certain quality to vibe and energy that is Sodo Sopa, from the independent merchants and unique cafes to the rustic charm
“No-B”这个称呼让我觉得很不舒服。这些缩写的社区名称简直是陈词滥调。就像《南方公园》里有一集，城里的一部分被重新命名为“南方公园市中心以南”，即Sodo Sopa。Sodo Sopa有一种特定的氛围和活力，从独立商户和独特的咖啡馆，到那种质朴的魅力，
of a mixed-income crowd. In an episode of How I Met Your Mother, two characters by an apartment in Doe, Satripla. of a rustic charm of a mixed-income crowd. Soho, try back on Noleita. Oh, right. Doe is a tree plough. No, I'm from New York. I know this neighborhood. Doe is a tree plough turns out to be short for Downwind of the sewage treatment plant. There are brokers who will be naming parts of Harlem as so-ha parts of little Italy, as Noleita,
以及混合收入人群的氛围。在《老爸老妈浪漫史》的一集中，两个角色在Doe, Satripla买了一套公寓。哦，对了。Doe是“树犁”的缩写。不，我来自纽约。我知道这个社区。Doe是“树犁”原来是“污水处理厂下风处”的缩写。有些经纪人会把哈莱姆区的部分地区命名为SoHa，把小意大利的部分地区命名为NoLita，
marketing the Bronx, as so-bro. This is Congressman Hakeem Jeffries. He represents New York's eighth congressional district, which is Brooklyn and parts of Queens. These are names that are created out of thin air, their fantasy, their fiction, their made up, solely in my view, to artificially inflate prices. Before Congressman Jeffries was elected to the House of Representatives, he was a member of the New York State Legislature,
把布朗克斯区营销为SoBro。这是哈基姆·杰弗里斯众议员。他代表纽约第八国会选区，包括布鲁克林和皇后区的部分地区。这些名字是凭空捏造出来的，是幻想，是虚构，在我看来，它们完全是为了人为地抬高价格。在杰弗里斯众议员当选众议院议员之前，他是纽约州议会的议员，
and he saw these neighborhood abbreviations creep into his own country. prices. Before Congressman Jeffries was elected to the House of Representatives, he was a member of the New York State Legislature, and he saw these neighborhood abbreviations creep into his jurisdiction. Real estate brokers were renaming parts of Crown Heights as Pro-Crow. That's Pro-Crow, PRO-CRO, which is a combination, apparently, of the prospect heights neighborhood and crown heights to its east. Properties and prospect heights have generally sold for more than those in crown heights. By making this new neighborhood, Pro Crow, brokers could sell crown heights properties at prospect heights prices.
他看到这些社区缩写渗透到了他自己的辖区。房地产经纪人正在把皇冠高地的部分地区重新命名为Pro-Crow。就是Pro-Crow，P-R-O-C-R-O，显然这是展望高地社区和它东边的皇冠高地的组合。展望高地的房产通常比皇冠高地的卖得贵。通过创造这个新社区“Pro-Crow”，经纪人可以以展望高地的价格出售皇冠高地的房产。
Congressman Jeffries did not like anything about this. He didn't like the sound of Pro Crow, and he didn't like what the name was trying to do. So he tried to stop it. When we researched the issue, it turned out that there was no sort of governmental entity involved in the designation of neighborhoods. In 2011, Jeffries proposed the Neighborhood Integrity Act, which set out to create guidelines and regulations
杰弗里斯众议员对这一切都不满意。他不喜欢Pro-Crow这个名字，也不喜欢这个名字背后的意图。所以他试图阻止它。当我们研究这个问题时，发现没有任何政府实体参与社区的命名。2011年，杰弗里斯提出了《社区完整性法案》，旨在为
for new neighborhood names and boundaries. But it turned out that it's hard to pass a law against names. The Neighborhood Integrity Act didn't gain traction, but neither did the name Pro Crow. Why don't you point out some names don't stick. Pro Crow was just silly, thankfully. It was abandoned. You never really know which of these names will stick around. Like there's this part of Midtown Manhattan that was recently renamed Nomad for North of
新的社区名称和边界制定指导方针和法规。但事实证明，很难通过一项针对名字的法律。《社区完整性法案》没有获得支持，但Pro-Crow这个名字也没能流行起来。你为什么不指出有些名字就是叫不响呢？谢天谢地，Pro-Crow太傻了。它被废弃了。你永远不知道这些名字中哪些会留下来。就像曼哈顿中城有一部分最近被重新命名为NoMad，意为“麦迪逊大道以北”。
Madison Avenue. And people are starting to use it. You can see it on Google Maps. And it's weird, there's not really a name for this naming convention. Like Noho, Sobro, Nomah. They're not quite acronyms, they're not quite portmanteaux, they're not just abbreviations. Around the office, we've been calling them acronyms, or if you want to get in the spirit of the thing, Akinas. Akinas is too much, that's not going to be a thing.
人们开始使用它了。你可以在谷歌地图上看到它。这很奇怪，这种命名惯例并没有真正的名称。比如NoHo、SoBro、NoMa。它们不完全是首字母缩略词，不完全是混成词，也不仅仅是缩写。在办公室里，我们一直称它们为“缩略名”，或者如果你想更有趣点，叫“Akinas”。Akinas太夸张了，那不会成为一个词。
Fine, they're acronyms, and they trace their lineage back to Soho, short for South of Houston Street in New York. It's really interesting how Soho developed first as a local neighborhood brand and then became globalized. Sharon Zoukin is a professor of sociology at Brooklyn College and the Graduate Center of the City University of New York. You have neighborhoods of Boston and Washington DC and Seattle and Denver abbreviated as Lodo, Sodo, Soma, Sowa, trading on the brand name of Soho. Now there already was a Soho district in London, but as the illusionists Helen Zaltzman will tell you that is not an acronym.
好吧，它们就是缩略名，它们的血统可以追溯到SoHo，即纽约“休斯顿街以南”的缩写。SoHo最初作为一个本地社区品牌发展，后来走向全球，这真的很有趣。莎伦·祖金是布鲁克林学院和纽约市立大学研究生中心的社会学教授。波士顿、华盛顿特区、西雅图和丹佛都有社区被缩写为LoDo、SoDo、SoMa、SoWa，都是在借用SoHo的品牌名。伦敦其实早就有个SoHo区，但正如《幻觉师》海伦·扎尔茨曼会告诉你的那样，那不是一个缩略词。
Most of the evidence points to it having been a hunting cry, soho, like tallyho, because soho stands on what used to be hunting land. Other people will tell you that soho is a shortening of south of Hobern, but those people are willfully ignoring the fact that soho is actually west of the area of Hobern, which would make soho weho, which it isn't. London Soho may have been first, but the American abbreviation of Soho and the birth of the acronym can be traced back to 1962
大多数证据表明它曾是一种狩猎时的呼喊声，“soho”，就像“tallyho”一样，因为SoHo坐落在曾经的狩猎场上。其他人会告诉你SoHo是“霍本以南”的缩写，但这些人故意忽略了一个事实，即SoHo实际上位于霍本区域的西边，那应该叫WeHo，但它并不是。伦敦的SoHo可能是最早的，但美国对SoHo的缩写和缩略名的诞生可以追溯到1962年，
and a fellow by the name of Chester Rapkin. He was an urban planner and eventually a member of the New York City Planning Commission from the late 60s to the late 1970s. And he was asked to investigate the conditions in what he called or what the City Planning Commission called the South-Houston industrial area. A lot of people think that the resulting paper, known as the Rappkin Report, invented the term Soho.
以及一个叫切斯特·拉普金的人。他是一位城市规划师，后来在60年代末到70年代末担任纽约市规划委员会成员。他被要求调查他所称的——或者说市规划委员会所称的——“南休斯顿工业区”的情况。很多人认为由此产生的报告，即《拉普金报告》，发明了“SoHo”这个词。
Now, I have recently read that report, and I do not believe that Rappkin used the term Soho in that report. It's also been said that Rappkin coined the term Soho in conversation. However, it happened around this time. People seized upon the term Soho as an abbreviation, which was certainly better than the South House in industrial area, but not nearly as bad as its previous name, Hell's Hundred Acres.
现在，我最近读了那份报告，我不认为拉普金在报告中使用了“SoHo”这个词。也有人说拉普金是在谈话中创造了“SoHo”这个词。无论如何，它大约是在那个时候出现的。人们抓住了“SoHo”这个缩写，这当然比“南休斯顿工业区”好听，但远没有它之前的名字“地狱百英亩”那么糟糕。
In the 1950s and early 60s, Soho was zoned for industrial manufacturing, but a lot of the buildings were empty. At the time, Rappkin was riding the report, it was not the most pleasant part of town. He mentioned in passing the grim caverns of factory buildings in Soho, and that's absolutely true. The South-Houston industrial area was threatened with demolition. The brick buildings with cast iron facades were seen as ugly, outdated,
在20世纪50年代和60年代初，SoHo被划为工业制造业区，但许多建筑都是空的。拉普金写报告时，那里并不是城里最令人愉快的地方。他顺便提到了“SoHo工厂建筑的阴森洞穴”，这绝对是真的。南休斯顿工业区面临拆迁威胁。那些带有铸铁外墙的砖砌建筑被视为丑陋、过时、
eyesores. I mean, they were factories. Smack in the middle of downtown Manhattan. There had been a major pressure on the part of city government, as well as probably the real estate industry, to demolish these worthless buildings and replace them with one of the new residential projects. This was in the early 60s when New York City under the influence of Robert Moses was trying to tear down and rebuild. They were wrecking ball happy. But the Rappkin report made a plea to preserve the factory
碍眼的东西。我的意思是，它们是工厂。就在曼哈顿市中心。市政府以及房地产行业可能都曾施加巨大压力，要求拆除这些毫无价值的建筑，并用新的住宅项目取而代之。那是在60年代初，纽约市在罗伯特·摩西的影响下，试图拆除并重建。他们热衷于使用拆迁球。但拉普金报告呼吁保护这些工厂
buildings and the city held off on their plan. RAPKIN said the manufacturers in those buildings were viable and it would be interesting, maybe even great if the manufacturing buildings were renovated for manufacturing use. Nobody foresaw that the area would become colonized by artists. Artists rented the manufacturing spaces for studios and to save money they live there too. Soho in the 1970s quickly gained the identity of an artist's district. But the lofts weren't supposed to be residential. They weren't up to city housing standards, state standards, fire codes, anything. For a while, the city skirted around this problem
建筑，市政府搁置了他们的计划。拉普金说，这些建筑里的制造商是可行的，如果这些制造建筑能翻新用于制造业，那将是很有趣的，甚至是很棒的。没人预见到该地区会被艺术家殖民。艺术家们租用制造空间作为工作室，为了省钱，他们也住在那里。20世纪70年代的SoHo很快获得了艺术家区的身份。但这些阁楼本不应该是住宅。它们不符合城市的住房标准、州标准、消防法规等任何要求。有一段时间，市政府绕过了这个问题，
by classifying artists as machines who manufactured art and could thus stay in the factories overnight. performers and painters and musicians hosted happenings and art openings out of their lofts and these attracted attention from arts publications and newspapers. Soho was, if not the very first industrial district, to be transformed into live work and living space, it was certainly the most prominent in the media.
将艺术家归类为“制造艺术的机器”，因此可以留在工厂过夜。表演者、画家和音乐家在他们的阁楼里举办活动和艺术开幕式，这些吸引了艺术出版物和报纸的注意。SoHo即使不是第一个被改造成居住工作空间的工业区，也绝对是媒体中最突出的一个。
After the success of Soho, the urban planning department wanted to do on purpose what had happened by accident in Soho. They set their sights on a nearby area, the Triangle Below Canal Street, or as they called it, Tribeca. Tribeca was also a former manufacturing district, but it was intentionally re-zoned for mixed use. So now factories and residences and galleries could exist side by side legally.
在SoHo成功之后，城市规划部门想要故意做成在SoHo偶然发生的事情。他们把目光投向了附近的一个区域，即“运河街以下三角区”，或者他们称之为Tribeca（翠贝卡）。翠贝卡也曾是一个制造业区，但它被有意重新规划为混合用途。所以现在工厂、住宅和画廊可以合法地并存。
You know the story from here. Artists moved into the old lofts, made them seem hip and desirable, and higher income residences and businesses slowly took over. And now of course, Soho and Tribeca are fancy, fancy places. Full of boutiques and high-end residences all housed in the architectural skeletons of old industry. Soho was able to incubate and disseminate all of these trends that became
你从这里开始就知道这个故事了。艺术家们搬进旧阁楼，使它们看起来时髦且令人向往，高收入的住宅和企业慢慢接管了这里。现在当然，SoHo和翠贝卡是极其高档的地方。到处都是精品店和高端住宅，都坐落在旧工业的建筑骨架中。SoHo能够孵化并传播所有这些在80年代和90年代，甚至可能一直持续到2000年代，
so important in interior design in the 80s and 90s and you know probably on into the 2000s. Soho and Tribeca weren't just the rise of acronyms. They were the birth of industrial chic. They created the whole aesthetic that comes to mind with these neighborhoods. In Soho artists embraced the vestiges of the factories they were living and working in. They found the big metal fixtures and beams and loading docks charming. And this became a kind of expensive minimalism that marked high status taste in interior design. Exposed brick walls, distressed floors, big windows, large open spaces, big beams
在室内设计中变得如此重要的趋势。SoHo和翠贝卡不仅仅是缩略名的兴起。它们是“工业风”的诞生。它们创造了人们想到这些社区时脑海中浮现的整个美学。在SoHo，艺术家们拥抱了他们居住和工作的工厂遗迹。他们发现那些巨大的金属装置、横梁和装卸码头很有魅力。这变成了一种昂贵的极简主义，标志着室内设计中高地位的品味。裸露的砖墙、做旧的地板、大窗户、宽敞的开放空间、大横梁
and bronze fixtures, the old factories became trendy and new wealthier residents added layers of conventional luxury. Now people install very expensive marble baths and floors and wine vaults into former industrial lofts so that the simplicity of the first generation of industrial chic has turned into the excess of the current multimillion dollar lofts. Lofts in these genuine old buildings now go for millions of dollars, and new condos and developments are actively trying to look like old warehouses. And in other parts of New York and other cities around the world, developers started to copy
和青铜装置，旧工厂变得时髦起来，新的富裕居民增加了传统奢华的层次。现在人们在旧工业阁楼里安装非常昂贵的大理石浴缸、地板和酒窖，以至于第一代工业风的简洁已经变成了现在价值数百万美元的阁楼的过度奢华。这些真正的老建筑里的阁楼现在卖到数百万美元，新的公寓和开发项目正积极地试图看起来像旧仓库。在纽约的其他地方和世界各地的其他城市，开发商开始复制
so-ho, not just in industrial areas, but in all kinds of neighborhoods, independent of whoever was already living or working there. Real estate developers around the world copy this and they say, let's bring some stores. Let's encourage some performance spaces, some art galleries. Let's make this area interesting. Let's give it a name. And as time went on, a new name, especially an acronym,
SoHo，不仅是在工业区，而是在各种各样的社区，不管那里已经住着或工作着什么人。世界各地的房地产开发商复制这一点，他们说，让我们引进一些商店。让我们鼓励一些表演空间、一些艺术画廊。让我们让这个区域变得有趣。让我们给它起个名字。随着时间的推移，一个新的名字，尤其是缩略名，
became the big indicator that your neighborhood was about to change. What we're seeing is something of an era of gentrification. This is Jacqueline Huang, a postdoctoral research fellow at Princeton University. In 2006, she did a comprehensive study of residents in a section of South Philadelphia, where she basically went up to them and asked, what do you call your neighborhood? So in this section of Philly, most of the minority residents refer to it as South Philly.
成为了你的社区即将发生改变的重要标志。我们所看到的是某种绅士化时代。这是杰奎琳·黄，普林斯顿大学的博士后研究员。2006年，她对南费城一个区域的居民进行了一项全面的研究，她基本上走到他们面前问，你们称这个社区为什么？所以在费城的这一区，大多数少数族裔居民称之为“南费城”。
But not the new mostly white residents and the real estate agents and Craigslist posts that listed the properties. Most commonly they use the name Graduate Hospital, so named because a hospital used to be in that neighborhood. Other people have referred to it as Geho, Soso, which is so-so to represent South of South Street. Even if they groaned or laughed at GehoH-O or so-so, these newcomers really identified more with graduate hospital than south Philly.
但新的以白人为主的居民、房地产经纪人和列出房产的Craigslist帖子却不是这样。他们最常使用“研究生医院”这个名字，因为以前那里有一家医院。其他人称之为GeHo，或者SoSo，即“南街以南”的缩写。即使他们对GeHo或SoSo感到厌烦或嘲笑，这些新来者确实比“南费城”更认同“研究生医院”。
Now, just to be clear, neighborhoods do shift and change names periodically. But Jacqueline says the recent naming rush is different. I would say that there's an intention behind this and sort of a power play happening. You know, there's a group that's redefining it while another group is trying to hold on to this older name. As cities boom and gentrification rises, new neighborhoods get made and new names proliferate. I'm not saying neighborhood change is not good for these neighborhoods. They certainly need the investment, but I think the idea that there's this alienation
现在，需要明确的是，社区确实会定期更名和改变。但杰奎琳说，最近的命名热潮是不同的。我想说，这背后是有意图的，是一种权力博弈。你知道，有一个群体正在重新定义它，而另一个群体正试图坚持这个旧名字。随着城市繁荣和绅士化加剧，新的社区被创造出来，新的名字层出不穷。我并不是说社区改变对这些社区不好。它们确实需要投资，但我认为这种疏离感
that's taking place and that, you know, it's intentional of displacing and devaluing the previous name in order to make the neighborhood change faster. This gets at the icky-ness, I feel, about using the term nobi to describe where I live. I don't want to be the newcomer who alienates the old residents by using some term that was fed to me by real estate developers. But nobi is also useful because it's specific
正在发生，而且你知道，这是为了让社区更快改变而故意排挤和贬低旧名字。这触及了我对使用“No-B”来描述我住的地方所感到的那种不适感。我不想成为那个通过使用房地产开发商喂给我的术语而疏远老居民的新来者。但No-B也很有用，因为它很具体，
and it's efficient. I mean, saying I live in nobi is obviously faster than saying I live at the border of North Oakland, Berkeley Berkeley and Emoryville. Well, I live in Dobi, which is downtown Berkeley. I just made up the name Dobi. That is comedian and longtime Bay Area resident W. Kamal Bell. I was thinking about my neighborhood and gentrification when I happened to run into him
而且很高效。我的意思是，说我住在No-B显然比说我住在北奥克兰、伯克利和埃默里维尔的交界处要快。嗯，我住在Do-B，也就是伯克利市中心。我刚编造了Do-B这个名字。那是喜剧演员和长期居住在湾区的W·卡马尔·贝尔。我正在思考我的社区和绅士化问题时，碰巧遇到了他，
appropriately at the South Berkeley Farmers Market. I know they call it the South Berkeley farmers market, but I've lived in the Bay Area long enough to remember when this was called Oakland right here. This feels like South, South, South, South, South Berkeley. Kamal feels uncomfortable with these acronyms too. Kono, what's they're trying to make downtown? Kono, what is that?
地点很合适，在南伯克利农贸市场。我知道他们称之为南伯克利农贸市场，但我住在湾区的时间足够长，记得这里曾经被称为奥克兰。这感觉像是南、南、南、南、南伯克利。卡马尔对这些缩略名也感到不舒服。Kono，他们试图把市中心变成什么？Kono，那是什么？
Korea town market. Kono? Kono. Oh no. But he says, if you're focused too much on neighborhood names, you might be missing the point. And this is just symptomatic of like, this is like the neighborhood name is like
韩国城北门。Kono？Kono。噢，不。但他表示，如果你太关注社区名称，你可能会忽略重点。这只是症状，就像社区名称就像
the old log in the woods, and you lift up the neighborhood name and you see all the bugs underneath, and that's gentrification. If you get too focused on the name, you're probably not focused on what's going on under the wood. Acronames are easy to lampoon. They're ubiquitous to the point of parody and often cringe-worthy. So we may see a shift away from these names.
树林里的旧圆木，你掀开社区名称，就会看到下面所有的虫子，那就是绅士化。如果你太关注名字，你可能就没有关注圆木下面正在发生什么。缩略名很容易被讽刺。它们无处不在，甚至到了滑稽的地步，而且常常让人尴尬。所以我们可能会看到人们不再使用这些名字。
Real estate developers will start using less silly sounding names to market neighborhoods to higher paying customers. These names might sound more authentic like graduate hospital and philly or temescal in Oakland, but they're different names for the same thing, the same log over the ants of gentrification. And as far as what you should call your neighborhood, if you're a newcomer? I mean, I feel like the bigger issue is to respect the neighborhood you're moving into. If you respect the neighborhood you're moving into and you aren't trying to be the change,
房地产开发商将开始使用听起来不那么傻的名字来向高收入客户推销社区。这些名字听起来可能更地道，比如费城的“研究生医院”或奥克兰的“特梅斯卡尔”，但它们是同一事物的不同名称，是绅士化蚂蚁之上的同一根圆木。至于如果你是一个新来者，你应该怎么称呼你的社区？我的意思是，我觉得更大的问题是尊重你搬入的社区。如果你尊重你搬入的社区，并且你不是试图成为改变者，
you're trying to be the blend, then you should then whatever the people in the neighborhood call it, then call it that. So I took Kamau's advice. I walked around my block and I asked people, what do you call this neighborhood? And I met a few newcomers like me who were just as confused as I was. Was it No-B, was it the Ashby Bart region,
你是试图融入其中，那么无论社区里的人怎么称呼它，你就怎么称呼它。所以我采纳了卡马尔的建议。我在街区周围走了一圈，问人们，你们称这个社区为什么？我遇到了一些像我一样的新来者，他们和我一样困惑。是No-B吗？是阿什比捷运站区域吗？
the Golden Gate District, the Lauren district, but the neighbors who've lived here for a while all said the same thing. It's just North Oakland. And really, it doesn't need to be called anything else. Can I put you in there? Can I use the stairs? Oh, you're talking what are you talking about? Can you put me on that empty invisible? Hashtag life goals. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Trouffleman
金门区，劳伦区？但在这里住了很久的邻居们都说了同样的话。这只是北奥克兰。真的，它不需要被叫成别的名字。我可以把你放进去吗？我可以用楼梯吗？哦，你在说什么？你能把我放进那个“隐形”里吗？#生活目标。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，
With Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Delini Hall, Kurt Colstead, Shereef, Yusef, and me Roman Mars Special thanks this week to Jeff Bliss, Tim Wong, W. Camel Bell, and Helen Zoltzman. You should already be downloading Helen's Radiotopia podcast, The Illusionists on your favorite podcasting app, but if not, take this opportunity to remedy that. Kamal Bell hosts a new radio show and podcast called Kamal right now, which I highly recommend its a live talk show based here in the Bay, it's produced by KALW, the greatest radio station in the world. We are a
凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、德利尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、谢里夫·尤瑟夫和我罗曼·马尔斯参与制作。本周特别感谢杰夫·布利斯、蒂姆·王、W·卡马尔·贝尔和海伦·扎尔茨曼。你应该已经在你最喜欢的播客应用上下载海伦的Radiotopia播客《幻觉师》了，如果没有，请借此机会补上。卡马尔·贝尔主持了一个新的广播节目和播客，叫《卡马尔现在》，我强烈推荐，这是一个在湾区直播的谈话节目，由世界上最伟大的广播电台KALW制作。我们是
product of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interior firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join the fine community of people who like this show on Facebook. I fave every 99pi coin I see on Twitter and Instagram every single one of them makes me happy when I see them. So please keep sending them in. But if you want to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world, I recommend you spend some time perusing 99pi.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
91.7 KALW旧金山的产物，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Arxine建筑和室内设计公司办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入喜欢这个节目的优秀社区。我在Twitter和Instagram上收藏了我看到的每一个99pi硬币，每一个都让我看到时感到高兴。所以请继续发送它们。但如果你想探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动，我建议你花点时间浏览99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。